THANK YOU SO MUCH, KRISTIN.
LET’S BRING IN KELLYANNE CONWAY
COUNSELOR TO THE PRESIDENT TO
REACT TO THIS.
GOOD MORNING, KELLYANNE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: WHAT IS YOUR REACTION
TO WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO ADD MY VOICE
TORE THANKING THE SECRET SERVICE
THEY ARE INCREDIBLE MEN AND
WOMEN.
THEY DID INCREDIBLE JOB HERE.
YOU SAW THE PRESIDENT RESUME HIS
DUTIES.
THAT’S VERY DONALD TRUMP ALSO.
THE SHOW MUST GO ON.
THE BRIEFING MUST GO ON.
THE VIOLENCE INTERRUPTING OUR
CITIES BIGGER STORY HERE.
LOOK AT CHICAGO BEAUTIFUL
AMERICAN CITY.
THEY HAVE HAD 414 PEOPLE
MURDERED THIS YEAR OVER ROUGHLY
50% INCREASE OVER LAST YEAR.
1900 PEOPLE SHOT, INCLUDING
THESE KIDS.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, JUST STOP
AND THINK ABOUT THE NINE
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN MURDERED
IN CHICAGO THIS YEAR THROUGH
GUNSHOTS.
A LITTLE BOY 3 YEARS OLD IN THE
BACK OF HIS PARENTS’ CAR JUST
RIDE AG LONG.
A 13-YEAR-OLD IN HER HOUSE IN
FRONT OF HER ENTIRE FAMILY
JUSTOVER NIGHT YOU HAVE
ALLEGEDLY THE SEATTLE POLICE
CHIEF CARMEN BEST BEEN ON YOUR
NETWORK SEVERAL TIMES SEARCHING
28 YEARS.
POLICE CHIEF AFRICAN-AMERICAN
WOMAN RESIGNING BECAUSE THE
COUNCIL IS MAKING GOOD ON ITS
PROMISE TO CUT THE BUDGET THERE
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT WOULD HAVE REDUCED OVER 100
OFFICERS.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS IN THE SHADOW
OF THE GALLUP POLL LAST WEEK
THAT SHOWED 86% OF AMERICANS
WANT THE SAME OR MORE POLICE
PRESENCE IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND THAT INCLUDES 83% OF
HISPANIC AMERICANS AND 81
PORTION OF81% OFAFRICAN-AMERICAN
WHAT’S REALLY INCREDIBLE I SEE
THESE MAYORS IN THEIR PRESS
CONFERENCES AND REALLY SHAMELESS
BUT NOT BLAMELESS AND NOT
NAMELESS.
WHAT THE MOST COMMON WORD THEY
SAY IN THEIR PRESS CONFERENCES?
NOT POLICE, NOT SYMPATHY, TRUMP
TRUMP TRUMP TRUMP TRUMP.
WE WILL NOT HAVE THE PRESIDENT
AND THE FEDS HERE.
EVERYBODY FLEXING THEIR SOCIAL
MEDIA MUSCLE.
THEY ARE ALL SO TOUGH AND IT
JUST MEANS THAT PEOPLE ARE
SHOVELING HATE AT POLICE
OFFICERS, SHOVELING HATE AT
PEOPLE WHO WORK HERE.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE ALSO
WORRIED THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
GOING TO GET FOUR MORE YEARS AND
THEY’RE STARTING TO LOSE IT.
AND YOU SEE THAT HERE AND
ELSEWHERE YESTERDAY AS WELL.
STEVE: DO YOU SEE A LOT OF TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME AND WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THAT FOR A
WHILE, KELLYANNE.
OF COURSE, THAT SHOOTING
OCCURRED JUST AS THE PRESIDENT
WAS STARTING HIS CORONAVIRUS
BRIEFING IN THE BRIEFING ROOM.
THE BIG -- WHICH IS GREAT
BECAUSE HE UPDATES US ON WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN THE UNITED STATES.
THERE IS INTERNATIONAL NEWS THIS
MORNING AND THAT IS RUSSIA
CLAIMS THAT THEY HAVE NOW
DEVELOPED A COVID-19 VACCINE AND
THEY ARE GOING TO START
VACCINATING MILLIONS OF TEACHERS
AND FRONT LINE HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THIS MONTH.
BUT, YOU KNOW, BEHIND THAT
HEADLINE I WAS READING THAT THE
TESTING HAS BEEN REALLY SMALL
AND SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING WE
DON’T KNOW IF THIS IS SAFE.
APPARENTLY THEY HAVE GIVEN IT TO
SOME OF THE SCIENTISTS WHO
WORKED ON IT AND 50 MILITARY
MEMBERS AND SOME VOLUNTEERS BUT
THAT IS NOT THE LARGE TESTING
GROUP THAT WE’RE USED TO SEEING.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
THAT’S WHY THE U.S. STANDARDS
ARE SO MUCH MORE STRINGENT.
OF COURSE, OUR FDA IN OUR
COUNTRY SETS THE STANDARDS AND
WHAT I UNDERSTAND FROM THE
RUSSIA ANNOUNCEMENT IS THIS IS
NOWHERE NEAR WHERE WE ARE.
WHICH IS WE HAVE SIX DIFFERENT
VACCINE CANDIDATES INTO PHASE 3.
AND THEY DON’T SEEM TO BE THERE
YET.
AND EVEN DR. ANTHONY FAUCI
EARLIER THIS MONTH TESTIFIED
UNDER OATH IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
AND SAYS HE HOPES WHEN CHINA AND
RUSSIA ARE RELEASING THEIR
VACCINES THEY HAVE GONE THROUGH
RIGOROUS TESTING AT THE VERY
LEAST.
HE SAID IT WOULD BE PROBLEMATIC
IF THAT WERE NOT TRUE.
THE PRESIDENT IS GETTING VACCINE
UPDATE HERE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
TODAY.
I’M SURE HE WILL ANNOUNCE THAT
IN AN OPEN PRESS EVENT AND
HOPEFULLY AT HIS PRESSER LATER
ON TODAY.
WHAT HE WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
ARE THESE SIX CANDIDATES
INCLUDING OPERATION WARPED SPEED
WHICH HAS JUST BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE SUCCESS TO DATE.
WE -- NIH DIRECTOR DR. COLLINS
SAID RECENTLY HE HAS BEEN THERE
FOR DECADES.
HE HAS NEVER SEEN SOMETHING COME
TOGETHER SO SWIFTLY AND SO
SUCCESSFULLY.
RESULTS AMERICANS WHAT THEY NEED
TO KNOW WE ARE IN THE FINAL
PHASES WITH A COUPLE OF THOSE
SIX CANDIDATE VACCINE CANDIDATES
AND WE THINK WE CAN HAVE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOSES IN
THE NEXT MONTH ALONE.
BRIAN: CAN’T WAIT FOR UPDATE.
>> THESE ARE HOUSEHOLDS LIKE
MODERNA AND JOHNSON AND JOHNSON.
BRIAN: KELLYANNE CAN WE TALK
REAL QUICK IN THE MINUTE OR SO
WE HAVE LEFT WHAT’S GOING ON
WITH THE RESCUE PACKAGE.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTS
TODAY THE WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS,
THAT MIGHT BE YOU, BELIEVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS GAINED
LEVERAGE WITH HIS EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO REACH OUT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE IN ORDER TO RESUME TALKS
OR MIGHT THE WHITE HOUSE AND
LEADERSHIP REACH OUT TO
DEMOCRATS?
>> IT CAN GO EITHER WAY.
WE HAVE NEVER STOPPED TALKING.
THE PRESIDENT SAID YESTERDAY
THEY HAVE HIS PHONE NUMBER.
THEY KNOW WHERE HE LIVES AND
WORKS, ALSO WE HAVE OUR CHIEF
NEGOTIATORS STILL VERY MUCH
INVOLVED IN THE GAME.
AND I THINK WHAT THE PRESIDENT
DID THIS WEEKEND SHOWED AMERICA
TWO BIG THINGS.
NUMBER ONE IS IN THE ABSENCE OF
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERSHIP AND
ACTION, THIS PRESIDENT WILL
ALWAYS STEP INTO THE BREACH AND
NUMBER TWO, WHAT THE PRESIDENT
DID IS HE BASICALLY TOLD AMERICA
WHEN YOU LOOK AT YOUR MONTHLY
BILLS.
I’M TRYING TO HELP YOU STAY IN
YOUR HOMES OR YOUR APARTMENTS
THROUGH THE NON-EVICTION
NOTICES -- NON-EVICTION RELIEF.
ALSO, GET SOME MORE MONEY FOR
THE $400 PLUS ON TOP OF WHATEVER
YOU ARE ALREADY RECEIVING SO CAN
HELP WITH YOU FOOD OR MEDICINE
OR MEET OTHER HOUSEHOLD
EXPENSES.
AND, ALSO, THE PRESIDENT GAVE
RELIEF FOR THE REST OF 2020,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, FOR
STUDENT LOAN PAYMENTS THAT
FORBEARANCE WILL HELP SO MANY
PEOPLE STARING AT DIFFERENT
BILLS EVERY MONTH AND SAYING I
CAN’T MEET MY BASIC EXPENSES.
I CAN’T SLEEP AT NIGHT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
DID AND THEIR FRIENDS IN THE
MEDIA YET I REPEAT MYSELF?
THEY ATTACKED IT OH, THIS CAN’T
BE AND YOU DIDN’T DO -- WELL,
CONGRESS, STEP UP, STEP.
IN I NOTICED A NUMBER OF THOSE
LEADERS, QUOTE, UNQUOTE, VERY
GENEROUS OF ME IN CONGRESS ARE
SPEAKING AT THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION.
MAKE CHUCK SCHUMER CAN USE HIS
CONVENTION SPEECH NEXT WEEK TO
ANNOUNCE THAT HE HAS A RELIEF
PACKAGE WITH THE REPUBLICANS AND
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT WOULD BE A MUCH BETTER USE
OF HIS TIME.
BRIAN: I AGREE.
>> THAN WHATEVER INVENTRICLIVES
THEY ARE GOING TO HURL AT THE
PRESIDENT.